Jake:我们一起对个时间
Jake: Let's sync our time together.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:但是你们可以先开始聊
Jake: But you guys can start chatting first.
Tasha: 那我们开始做早饭吧
Tasha: Then let's start making breakfast.
Lucia: 让我把这个眼镜刚好擦一下
Lucia: Let me just clean these glasses real quick.
Tasha: 我们去做那个面饼部分
Tasha: We'll handle the dough part.
Tasha: 你来冲咖啡或者做早上的牛牛奶
Tasha: You make the coffee or the morning milk.
Lucia: 可以可以你指哪种牛奶
Lucia: Sure, what kind of milk are you referring to?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶
Tasha: Fresh milk.
Lucia: 只要把牛奶倒出来就可以的牛奶吗
Lucia: The kind where you just pour it out?
Tasha: 热一热吧
Tasha: Heat it up a bit.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Tasha: 你早上喝冰牛奶吗
Tasha: Do you drink cold milk in the morning?
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我是说我以为你要给牛奶里面添加什么调味料什么的
Lucia: I thought you meant adding some flavor or something to the milk.
Tasha: 那我们那我们摊个饼吧就
Tasha: Then let's make some pancakes.
Jake:摊可以摊
Jake: Pancakes, sure.
Katrina:  都行
Katrina: That's fine.
Alice:咖啡在这个
Alice: The coffee is here.
Tasha: 你觉得这么多够了吗
Tasha: Do you think this is enough?
Alice:嗯能做
Alice: Yeah, that should work.
Tasha: 我觉只需要打3个蛋就够了啊
Tasha: I think just three eggs will be enough.
Alice: 2个
Alice: Two.
Katrina:  就是那天海底捞送的
Katrina: It's from the delivery that day.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, right.
Tasha: 好吧再来一些吧
Tasha: Okay, let's add some more.
Alice:哎呀差不多 因为我不吃
Alice: That's about right. I don't eat it anyway.
Jake: 带资进组
Jake: Funded the team.
Tasha: 那就这么多吧也不用做很多我觉得
Tasha: That's enough, we don't need to make too much.
Tasha: 毕竟中午还要吃饭
Tasha: After all, we still have lunch.
Tasha: 我就倒一一3个4个就行
Tasha: I'll just use three or four.
Tasha: 因为
Tasha: Because...
Alice:够吗
Alice: Is it enough?
Tasha: 再再倒一些
Tasha: Pour some more.
Lucia:  sorry按错键了
Lucia: Sorry, wrong button.
Jake: 好
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia: 再来一次
Lucia: Let's try again.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Uh-huh.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Jake: 先删掉吧
Jake: Let's delete it first.
Lucia:  sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake: 没关系挺好
Jake: It's okay, no problem.
Tasha: 就这样调面糊吧
Tasha: Let's mix the batter like this.
Tasha: 哈哈我们家就这样调然后直接开摊
Tasha: Haha, at our place, we mix it like this and then start the stall right away.
Jake: 多按了俩键问题不大
Jake: Pressing two extra buttons is not a big deal.
Katrina:  赠品
Katrina: Freebie.
Alice: 因为我一般用的是筷子
Alice: Because I usually use chopsticks.
Tasha: oh
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 有用过这个
Alice: I have used this before.
Tasha: 接瓶水
Tasha: Grab a bottle of water.
Tasha: 矿泉水
Tasha: Mineral water.
Lucia: 呃我时间是写10
Lucia: Um, I wrote the time as 10.
Alice: 我们应该放在那个大一点的面盆里
Alice: We should put it in a bigger mixing bowl.
Jake: 好的43 没没关系
Jake: Okay, 43. No worries.
Tasha: 嗯这个里面我主要觉得有这个嘴好摊
Tasha: Hmm, I think this spout is good for spreading.
Alice:你给我拿个筷子吧
Alice: Can you get me a pair of chopsticks?
Jake: 那你们俩聊聊舞蹈
Jake: Then you two can chat about dance.
Jake: 在冲完牛奶之后
Jake: After making the milk.
Lucia: 哎呦可以选一下
Lucia: Oh, you can choose one.
Jake: 哦对对然后你们可以在这比划比划
Jake: Oh yeah, and then you can practice a bit here.
Alice:这个
Alice: This.
Alice: 你们家里面鸡蛋饼是比较稀的
Alice: Are the egg pancakes at your place more watery?
Jake: 因为相机都给你们布好了
Jake: Because the cameras are all set up for you.
Alice: 还是比较稠的
Alice: Or are they thicker?
Jake: 哈哈哈二楼相机没有布好
Jake: Haha, the second-floor camera is not set up.
Tasha: 比较顺滑的
Tasha: They're smoother.
Jake: 所以没办法上去比划
Jake: So we can't go up there to practice.
Lucia: 这里如果有美团的话地址
Lucia: If we have Meituan here, the address...
Alice: 你看不好弄
Alice: Look, it's hard to manage.
Jake: 地址是怎么选地址是
Jake: How to choose the address is...
Alice: 拿个筷子，给他弄
Jake: 玉河区30玉河区53号你可以直接对
Jake: Yuhe District, No. 30 Yuhe District, No. 53, you can directly...
Tasha: 筷子还得洗
Tasha: The chopsticks need to be washed.
Alice: 你这个不也得洗吗
Alice: Doesn't this need to be washed too?
Lucia:  53号
Lucia: No. 53.
Alice: 给我吧
Alice: Give it to me.
Jake: 哦对就是把31改成53
Jake: Oh right, just change 31 to 53.
Jake: 因为31他找不到他要绕圈
Jake: Because he can't find 31, he has to go around.
Lucia:  我的网络又开始不太给力了
Lucia: My internet is starting to get weak again.
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia:  居然是这样
Lucia: Really, that's how it is.
Lucia:  要买一个碘伏脚蹭破了
Lucia: I need to buy some iodine solution, I scraped my foot.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 那我可以问问这个管家
Jake: Then I can ask the housekeeper.
Alice: 我先帮你搅着吧
Alice: I'll stir it for you first.
Lucia:  如果他有的话
Lucia: If he has some.
Katrina:  这边他们是不打扫卫生是吗
Katrina: They don't clean up here, do they?
Jake: 呃可以跟他们说他们就对
Jake: Uh, you can tell them, and they'll...
Lucia:  让他来打扫
Lucia: Ask him to clean.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:太绸了
Alice: It's too sticky.
Jake: 哎对京东是你要让让
Jake: Oh right, JD, you need to...
Jake: 你什么时候去
Jake: When are you going?
Tasha: 下午他走了
Tasha: He left this afternoon.
Jake: 嗯OK
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Katrina:  就是昨天我们拿快递那个
Katrina: It's the courier we picked up yesterday.
Katrina:  他不是固定的
Katrina: He's not regular.
Tasha: 感觉这个村
Tasha: Feels like this village...
Lucia:  我连维权有关系吗
Lucia: Does it have anything to do with our rights?
Katrina:  外来人员
Katrina: Outsiders.
Lucia:  但是我看对
Lucia: But I see, yeah.
Katrina:  随时来探望我们一下
Katrina: They can check on us anytime.
Jake: 卡住了是吗
Jake: Is it stuck?
Lucia:  我看我看
Lucia: I'll check, I'll check.
Jake: 应该没有什么
Jake: Shouldn't be a problem.
Lucia:  您好像能正确使用美团
Lucia: You seem to be able to use Meituan correctly.
Jake: 哈哈我觉得应该不是这个原因
Jake: Haha, I don't think that's the reason.
Lucia:  我觉得应该不是这个原因
Lucia: I don't think that's the reason.
Jake: 对美团的问题
Jake: It's a Meituan issue.
Jake: 这是那次海底捞的视频
Jake: This is the Haidilao video from that time.
Tasha: 它会再稀一点
Tasha: It'll get thinner.
Tasha: 面水加多了加面面加多了加水
Tasha: Add more water if it's too much dough, add more dough if it's too much water.
Alice:是这样的
Alice: That's how it is.
Jake: 这么多种子
Jake: So many seeds.
Jake: 他要种什么东西
Jake: What is he going to plant?
Katrina:  这应该是土吧
Katrina: This should be soil, right?
Katrina:  这是草莓
Katrina: These are strawberries.
Tasha: 那还剩了鸡蛋，怎么办呢，嘿嘿
Katrina:  这是赠送的樱桃萝卜
Katrina: These are the complimentary cherry radishes.
Jake: 啊还能种樱桃
Jake: Oh, we can even plant cherries.
Tasha: 先放进去
Tasha: Put it in first.
Jake: 呵呵樱桃不是种很久吗
Jake: Haha, don't cherries take a long time to grow?
Katrina:  哈哈海底捞
Katrina: Haha, Haidilao.
Katrina:  怎么海底捞的业务
Katrina: How's Haidilao's business?
Jake: 樱桃树你种过吗
Jake: Have you ever planted a cherry tree?
Katrina:  啊樱桃不是树吗
Katrina: Isn't a cherry a tree?
Tasha: 吃过算吗
Tasha: Does eating it count?
Katrina:  他怎么能给我种呢
Katrina: How can he plant it for me?
Jake: 呵呵呵吃过差不多
Jake: Haha, eating it is about the same.
Alice: 你要的稠度吗
Alice: Is this the consistency you want?
Tasha: 还要再稀一点
Tasha: It needs to be a bit thinner.
Alice: 那你得放水
Alice: Then you need to add water.
Jake: 点上了吗
Jake: Is it on?
Alice: 你就放这一点
Alice: Just put this much.
Lucia:  nope因为飘到外星球去了
Lucia: Nope, because it drifted to another planet.
Tasha: 我又怕放多了
Tasha: I'm afraid I'll add too much.
Jake: 我帮你点
Jake: I'll help you turn it on.
Alice: 没事我来了我就有点费劲
Alice: It's okay, I'll do it. It's a bit tricky.
Lucia:  奇怪啊
Lucia: Weird.
Jake: 你用的是美团外卖是吧
Jake: Are you using Meituan Waimai?
Lucia:  就我直接点了美团的APP
Lucia: Yeah, I just ordered through the Meituan app.
Lucia: 然后它里面会有这个
Lucia: And it has this option.
Lucia: 我刚才里面已经搞好了但是那是一个
Lucia: I just set it up, but it was...
Tasha: 想要不要那个搅拌器
Tasha: Do we need a blender?
Lucia:  51号是吗
Lucia: Number 51, right?
Tasha: 会不会搅拌的更顺一点
Tasha: Will it blend more smoothly?
Jake:  53
Jake: 53.
Lucia:  53 嗯
Lucia: 53, hmm.
Tasha: 感觉有颗粒感
Tasha: It feels grainy.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Lucia:  我是输入53吗
Lucia: Should I input 53?
Alice: 你不是要弄更多吗
Alice: Don't you want to make more?
Lucia:  因为我看他那里还有一个
Lucia: Because I see there's another one.
Lucia:  就是就算你输入
Lucia: Even if you input it...
Lucia:  他要你选定位还是什么的
Lucia: It asks you to select a location or something.
Jake: 您直接输就好了
Jake: Just input it directly.
Jake: 应该把那个53号
Jake: You should input number 53.
Tasha: 他最后就是滑起来没有阻力的那种
Tasha: In the end, it should blend smoothly without resistance.
Jake: 或者你用我这个号
Jake: Or you can use my number.
Tasha: 你懂我的状态吗
Tasha: Do you understand what I mean?
Alice: 其实
Alice: Actually,
Lucia:  为什么你的可以正常使用呢
Lucia: Why is yours working fine?
Alice: 蛋液应该后放
Alice: The egg mixture should be added later.
Jake: 因为我是美团外卖
Jake: Because I use Meituan delivery.
Alice: 因为蛋液一放进去
Alice: Because once you add the egg mixture,
Alice: 他把那个面给裹住了
Alice: it coats the dough.
Lucia:  哦我看一下您这个
Lucia: Oh, let me take a look at yours.
Jake: 我不知道美团有可能也有用
Jake: I don't know, maybe Meituan also works.
Alice: 还好
Alice: It's fine.
Alice: 没关系早饭而已
Alice: It's just breakfast, no big deal.
Lucia:  你的APP名字就叫美团外卖
Lucia: Your app is called Meituan delivery?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:  下个APP我操
Lucia: Download the app, damn.
Katrina:  舞蹈
Katrina: Dance.
Alice: 是你要的是再稀一点还是
Alice: Do you want it thinner, or...
Tasha: 我靠怎么这么稠真的是用低筋面粉吗
Tasha: Oh my, why is it so thick? Is it really low-gluten flour?
Tasha: 我怎么记得是用糯米粉
Tasha: I remember it should be glutinous rice flour.
Alice:什么 糯米粉
Alice: What? Glutinous rice flour?
Katrina:  那我们跳舞是不是还要带上羞涩一起
Katrina: Should we bring Shure along when we dance?
Tasha: 米粉我们家好像是用糯米粉
Tasha: At home, we use glutinous rice flour.
Lucia:  我也在想
Lucia: I was thinking the same.
Lucia:  至少我们练的时候要大家要带上
Lucia: At least when we practice, everyone should be included.
Tasha: 感觉这种有点起筋的感觉
Tasha: It feels more energetic this way.
Lucia:  那会很影响
Lucia: That would affect it a lot.
Katrina:  上再教他也没事
Katrina: Teaching him is fine too.
Lucia:  会影响一些动作
Lucia: It will affect some movements.
Katrina:  不是如果是有男生加入的话
Katrina: If a guy joins, the dance style would...
Alice: 这是低筋面粉
Alice: This is low-gluten flour.
Katrina:  那个舞蹈风格就
Katrina: The dance style would...
Alice: 没关系都是面
Alice: It's okay, it's all flour.
Jake: 你可以不加入
Jake: You don't have to join.
Tasha: 好奇怪啊
Tasha: That's strange.
Jake: 也可以加入都是你们说了算
Jake: Or you can join, it's up to you.
Lucia:  要不就加入吧
Lucia: How about we let him join?
Tasha: 这是最后一次水
Tasha: This is the last bit of water.
Katrina:  啊啊
Katrina: Ah, ah.
Lucia:  让人多一点显得有气势一些显得有
Lucia: Having more people would make it look more impressive.
Katrina:  来吧一起社死吧
Katrina: Come on, let's all socially die together.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: Let me do it.
Katrina:  我找找
Katrina: I'll look for it.
Katrina:  我问问我同学他们之前挑过什么
Katrina: I'll ask my classmates what they picked before.
Tasha: 天呐感觉很失败哈哈哈
Tasha: Oh my god, it feels like a failure, haha.
Alice: 你放调料了吗
Alice: Did you add the seasoning?
Tasha: 没有不是加糖吗
Tasha: No, wasn't I supposed to add sugar?
Lucia:  但我觉得我这次穿来的衣服里面
Lucia: But I think, among the clothes I brought this time,
Alice: 没加呢我不会做甜的
Alice: I haven't added it yet, I don't know how to make sweet dishes.
Lucia:  最适合的可能就是这条
Lucia: The most suitable might be this one.
Lucia:  这条裤子和那个白色上衣了
Lucia: These pants and that white top.
Tasha: 嗯我们是蘸也可以直接现在加
Tasha: Hmm, we can stick it now or add it directly.
Lucia:  我们也可以不那么统一
Lucia: We don't have to be that uniform.
Alice: 哎等一下这个是你想要的稠度吗
Alice: Hey, wait a sec, is this the thickness you wanted?
Lucia:  就是服装风格差不多就可以了
Lucia: As long as the style of the clothes is similar, it's fine.
Tasha: 可以吧差不多就这样吧
Tasha: It's okay, this should be fine.
Alice: 你放糖进去
Alice: Add the sugar.
Alice: 直接这样放糖它会不会不融化呀
Alice: If you add sugar directly like this, won't it not dissolve?
Tasha: 好吧那就这样吧
Tasha: Okay, then let's do it that way.
Alice: 你是不是得调糖水或者怎么的
Alice: Don't you need to mix it with water or something?
Katrina:  哎这好苦
Katrina: Ugh, this is so bitter.
Jake: 也也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake: 自己做不一定节省预预算
Jake: Making it yourself doesn't always save money.
Tasha: 嗯麻烦可恶仔
Tasha: Hmm, so troublesome, darn it.
Katrina:  我加了他倒进来就这么多
Katrina: I added it, and he poured in this much.
Katrina:  然后我加了这么多牛奶还是很苦
Katrina: Then I added this much milk, and it's still bitter.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia:  那都有谁喝咖啡啊
Lucia: So, who drinks coffee here?
Lucia:  我统计一下
Lucia: Let me do a count.
Lucia:  不喝咖啡的啊
Lucia: Anyone who doesn't drink coffee?
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Lucia:  一个你喝吗
Lucia: One, are you drinking?
Alice: 算了我不来了
Alice: Never mind, I won't have it.
Tasha: 我要喝牛奶
Tasha: I want milk.
Lucia:  呃要咖里面要不要咖啡您算上了
Lucia: Uh, do you want coffee in the milk?
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:  雨轩还喝咖啡吗
Lucia: Does Yuxuan still drink coffee?
Katrina:  这Wifi密码
Katrina: This Wifi password...
Jake: 哎呀挡住了挡住了挡住了
Jake: Oh no, it's blocked, blocked, blocked.
Lucia:  那现在就两个人挡住
Lucia: So now just two people are blocking it.
Jake: 对也挡住了
Jake: Yeah, it's blocked.
Katrina:  Wifi密码是多少上来的
Katrina: What's the Wifi password upstairs?
Jake: 这儿
Jake: Here.
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll get one.
Jake: 怎么还有指纹呢
Jake: Why are there still fingerprints?
Tasha: 来一个什么
Tasha: Get one of what?
Alice: 喝的
Alice: A drink.
Tasha: 你刚刚不是报名了咖啡吗
Tasha: Didn't you just sign up for coffee?
Alice: 对啊但是我又取消了
Alice: Yeah, but I canceled it.
Alice: 我现在报一下
Alice: I'm signing up again now.
Lucia:  啊那你重新报名哈哈
Lucia: Ah, so you're re-signing up, haha.
Lucia:  我们的咖啡名额减少到一个
Lucia: Our coffee slots are down to one.
Alice: 刚刚已经把我算上了总共才两个
Alice: They already counted me in, there were only two slots.
Lucia:  对对因为我我我现在不是特别困
Lucia: Yeah, because I'm not really tired right now.
Lucia:  所以我先不喝
Lucia: So I won't drink.
Alice: OK我只是想有个味道
Alice: OK, I just wanted the taste.
Lucia:  然后雨轩刚已经喝过了
Lucia: And Yuxuan already had some.
Lucia:  那你喝什么呢
Lucia: So what will you drink?
Alice: 咖啡吧
Alice: Coffee, I guess.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:  哎呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, haha.
Lucia:  对方撤出
Lucia: They withdrew.
Lucia:  撤回了一条消息又发送了
Lucia: They withdrew a message and sent it again.
Lucia:  一样的是吧
Lucia: The same one, right?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:  剩下的人都喝牛奶吗
Lucia: Is everyone else drinking milk?
Lucia:  嗯找一个小锅
Lucia: Hmm, find a small pot.
Jake: 路亚是买好了吗
Jake: Is the lure ready?
Tasha: 就是有点多
Tasha: There's quite a lot.
Lucia:  啊什么啊还没呢
Lucia: Ah, what? Not yet.
Jake: 买好还买
Jake: Ready, but still buying?
Jake: 那我先放在
Jake: I'll put it first.
Jake: 或者我联系一下修硕
Jake: Or I'll contact Shure.
Jake: 哎先联系一下收垃圾
Jake: Hey, contact garbage collection first.
Lucia:  或许可以问一下他们就是民宿这边
Lucia: Maybe we could ask the B&B here.
Tasha: 害怕了
Tasha: Scary.
Lucia:  有没有碘伏或者酒精
Lucia: If they have iodine or alcohol.
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Mmm, okay.
Alice: 都是食物我能做做不了，成什么样的，没关心
Lucia:  因为我我刚刷了一下
Lucia: Because I just refreshed it.
Lucia:  他还没有刷新出来
Lucia: And it hasn't refreshed yet.
Katrina:  你们听过这个歌吗
Katrina: Have you heard this song?
Katrina:  就这个舞很简单
Katrina: This dance is really simple.
Lucia:  我好像听过让我看一眼
Lucia: I think I've heard of it. Let me take a look.
Tasha: 加点面粉吧哈哈
Tasha: Add some flour, haha.
Katrina:  非常简单
Katrina: It's very simple.
Katrina:  就是人家跳年会的舞
Katrina: It's the dance people do at annual parties.
Katrina:  这是我们之前艺术团
Katrina: It's from our previous art troupe.
Lucia:  这个是一个抖音上很火的曲子吗
Lucia: Is this a popular song on Douyin?
Lucia:  觉得我好像在哪里听过
Lucia: I feel like I've heard it somewhere.
Katrina:  钥匙
Katrina: The key.
Alice: 可以吧我觉得这个差不多就好
Alice: It's fine, I think that's good enough.
Katrina:  非常经典的
Katrina: It's very classic.
Tasha: 可以吧可以
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine.
Alice: 帮你搅吧就有点费力费手
Alice: Let me stir it for you, it's a bit tiring.
Jake: 这这是哪年
Jake: When was this?
Jake: 零几年的歌还是八几年的歌呀
Jake: Is it a song from the 2000s or the 80s?
Alice: 没关系不用帮我弄
Alice: It's okay, you don't need to help me.
Katrina:  嗯呵
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  失恋阵线联盟
Katrina: "Love Linefront Alliance".
Jake: 这可能是八几年的歌
Jake: This might be from the 80s.
Katrina:  倒是很简单
Katrina: It's really simple.
Lucia:  这个还蛮简单的
Lucia: This is quite simple.
Katrina:  就当时我们艺术团
Katrina: Back then in our art troupe,
Katrina:  男生可以跳的
Katrina: even guys could do it.
Katrina:  多长时间
Katrina: How long?
Katrina:  2分42 跳个2分钟
Katrina: 2 minutes and 42 seconds, just dance for 2 minutes.
Katrina:  就跳个1分钟就可以了
Katrina: Just dancing for a minute is enough.
Lucia:  而且动作幅度也不大
Lucia: Plus the movements are not that big.
Lucia:  其实整体来说戴个眼镜也没什么怪
Lucia: Actually, wearing glasses doesn't look weird at all.
Lucia:  你看他们也戴着呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Look, they are wearing them too, haha.
Katrina:  哎对哦
Katrina: Oh yeah.
Alice: 薇薇好了
Alice: Tasha, it's ready.
Katrina:  我们可以搞一点造型pose
Katrina: We can do some poses.
Katrina:  一棵树哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Like a tree, hahaha.
Alice: 可以吗可以
Alice: Is it okay?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: It's fine.
Lucia:  啊哈哈哈 1棵树动作幅度这么大吗
Lucia: Hahaha, does a tree pose have such big movements?
Tasha: 我想看一下
Tasha: I want to see.
Katrina:  搞一个那个树的头套
Katrina: We'll make a tree headpiece.
Tasha: 那个铜锣烧是不是用低筋面粉
Lucia:  他现在加载出来了
Lucia: It's loading now.
Alice: 铜锣烧
Alice: Dorayaki
Katrina:  哦还有个你你你跳舞吗
Katrina: Oh, and do you, do you dance?
Tasha: 这什么
Tasha: What's this?
Katrina:  这不是修硕最爱的摇滚吗
Katrina: Isn't this Shure's favorite rock music?
Tasha: 糯米粉好吧
Tasha: Glutinous rice flour, okay
Tasha: 算了不学了
Tasha: Forget it, I'm not learning anymore
Katrina:  这也可以
Katrina: This works too
Katrina:  当我们闭室
Katrina: When we close the room
Tasha: 啊换个容器
Tasha: Ah, change the container
Lucia:  为什么这个
Lucia: Why this one?
Jake: 你们
Jake: You guys
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Lucia:  看起来有一点哈哈
Lucia: It looks a bit haha
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake: 你们想要换房间
Jake: Do you guys want to change rooms?
Katrina:  哎呦这还有一点什么元素呢
Katrina: Oh, there's still a bit of some element here
Alice: 所以一开始为什么不用它呢
Alice: So why didn't we use it from the beginning?
Jake: 你你你们想要打扫房间吗
Jake: Do you, do you guys want to clean the room?
Tasha: 呃我只是想过筛一下
Tasha: Uh, I just wanted to sift it
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake: 打房OK行
Jake: Cleaning the room, okay
Katrina:  还有换队形
Katrina: And change formation
Lucia:  是我们要现在收拾一下扫描吗
Lucia: Are we going to tidy up and scan now?
Alice: 这个稠度不好过筛
Alice: This consistency is not good for sifting
Jake: 呃也不是
Jake: Uh, not exactly
Jake: 就是可以换
Jake: It can be changed
Tasha: 嗯也好过吧
Tasha: Hmm, it's okay
Katrina:  哎这好看
Katrina: Oh, this looks nice
Katrina:  这比刚刚那好看
Katrina: This looks better than before
Alice: 呃那你试试吧
Alice: Uh, then you try it
Jake: 晚上我们也不是晚上
Jake: Tonight, we're not even tonight
Tasha: 感觉里面有颗粒
Tasha: Feels like there are particles inside
Jake: 可能下午我们就扫一下
Jake: Maybe we can clean up in the afternoon
Jake: 他们先帮你们扫一下
Jake: They can help you clean first
Jake: 你们再整理一下应该就好对
Jake: Then you can organize it, it should be fine, right?
Tasha: 但这个这个网确实太密了
Tasha: But this, this mesh is really too fine
Tasha: 哇像芝士
Tasha: Wow, looks like cheese
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's over
Tasha: 买的网太密了
Tasha: Bought a mesh that's too fine
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh crap
Tasha: 玛莎卡
Tasha: Mashaka
Alice: 我之前做章鱼小丸子的时候试过过筛
Alice: I tried sifting when I made takoyaki before.
Katrina:  这这怎么又是SOLO
Katrina: Why is this solo again?
Alice: 确实不好过筛
Alice: It's really hard to sift.
Katrina:  这咱就奇怪了
Katrina: This is so weird.
Lucia:  没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia:  我们可以把那个男生的站位给他删掉
Lucia: We can remove the boys' positions.
Lucia:  反正我们也没那么多人
Lucia: We don't have that many people anyway.
Tasha: 稍等我一下
Tasha: Wait a moment.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Alice: 其实做出来的差不多真的
Alice: This almost looks the same when made.
Alice: 就是有颗粒的话
Alice: But if there are granules...
Katrina:  偶像万万岁哦
Katrina: Long live idols!
Katrina:  高中的一个
Katrina: In high school...
Tasha: 确实不太好过
Tasha: It's really hard to sift.
Alice: 真的熟了之后没啥区别
Alice: Once it's cooked, there's no difference.
Katrina:  还有女团舞
Katrina: And girl group dances.
Alice: 就那个口感上煎饼那之类的
Alice: It's like the texture of pancakes and such.
Katrina:  哈哈哈先开始
Katrina: Haha, let's start.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Katrina:  嗯还有那个偶像万万岁
Katrina: Yeah, and long live idols.
Alice: 因为我之前做章鱼小丸子时候我就想着，过完筛
Alice: 他不是更细
Alice: It became finer.
Tasha: 更细
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 恩
Alice: 但是就是我那时候
Alice: But at that time...
Alice: 就是跟这种稠度差不多的那个
Alice: It was about the same consistency as this.
Alice: 过筛真是艰难的要死
Alice: Sifting was extremely difficult.
Tasha: 去哪过筛
Tasha: Where did you sift it?
Lucia:  啊他没有碘伏是吧
Lucia: Oh, he doesn't have iodine?
Lucia:  那我就在美团订一个
Lucia: I'll order one from Meituan then.
Alice: 这样吧没关系
Alice: It's fine this way.
Tasha: 可以没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Katrina:  我的未来事业
Katrina: My future career.
Tasha: 上锅
Tasha: On the stove.
Lucia:  53号楼
Lucia: Building 53.
Alice:油
Alice: Oil.
Tasha: 怎么
Tasha: What?
Alice: 油在这
Alice: The oil is here.
Tasha: 铲子
Tasha: Spatula.
Alice: 这个能高温不能
Alice: Can this handle high heat?
Katrina:  好像广播体操
Katrina: Feels like a radio exercise.
Tasha: 这个不能
Tasha: This won't work.
Alice: 不能
Alice: It won't work.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 靠这铲子怎么这么油
Tasha: Why is this spatula so greasy?
Tasha: 受不了了好黏糊
Tasha: I can't stand it, it's so sticky.
Alice:我喝凉的就行
Alice: I'll just drink it cold.
Alice: 不用给我弄热的
Alice: No need to heat it for me.
Lucia:  呃没事反正牛奶会变成热的
Lucia: Uh, it's okay, the milk will turn hot anyway.
Lucia:  所以你也可以加热牛奶
Lucia: So you can heat the milk too.
Lucia:  万一你in case you change your mind
Lucia: In case you change your mind.
Alice: 噢不不不哈哈
Alice: Oh no no no, haha.
Alice: 不不不不
Alice: No no no.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手啊
Jake: Hahaha, got it.
Tasha: 什么等等等等
Tasha: What, wait wait wait.
Alice: no no no no no
Alice: No no no no no.
Alice: 我不喝我不喝热的
Alice: I don't drink hot milk.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手
Jake: Hahaha, got it.
Tasha: 我不喝我不喝热的牛奶
Tasha: I don't drink hot milk.
Alice: 牛奶我喝凉的就行了啊
Alice: I'll just drink the milk cold.
Tasha: 我喝凉的就行啊
Tasha: I'll just drink it cold.
Tasha: 不要放在这里啊不我不放
Tasha: Don't put it here, no I won't put it.
Alice: 不要放在这里啊
Alice: Don't put it here.
Lucia:  不我不我不放我啊你
Lucia: No I won't I won't put it, you.
Alice: 不不放
Alice: No, don't put it.
Lucia:  你的意思是你要用这个锅是吗
Lucia: You mean you want to use this pot?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia:  啊没有没有我不用这个锅
Lucia: Ah no no, I won't use this pot.
Lucia:  我只是把这个在这里放一下
Lucia: I'm just putting this here for a bit.
Lucia:  然后找一个锅给它倒进去而已
Lucia: Then I'll find another pot to pour it into.
Lucia:  他这里有没有那种专门的牛奶壶
Lucia: Is there a special milk pot here?
Lucia:  感觉好像没有什么呃
Lucia: It feels like there isn't, uh.
Alice: 应该不会有
Alice: Probably not.
Lucia:  因为如果没有的话
Lucia: Because if there isn't,
Lucia:  那个那个锅用来热牛奶就太大了
Lucia: that pot is too big to heat milk.
Lucia:  感觉一个热进去才能把他
Lucia: It feels like it takes forever to heat it.
Alice: 我洗个杯子吧
Alice: I'll wash a cup.
Alice: 我不喝热的
Alice: I don't drink hot stuff.
Lucia:  才能把他盖到底的感觉
Lucia: It feels like it takes forever to heat it.
Lucia:  让我再看看
Lucia: Let me check again.
Alice: 我们都是用这种杯子是吗
Alice: We're all using these cups, right?
Lucia:  好像只有这种杯子耶
Lucia: Looks like we only have these cups.
Alice: 哦对好的
Alice: Oh, right, okay.
Alice: 那我洗一个吧
Alice: Then I'll wash one.
Lucia:  但你也可以用碗
Lucia: But you can also use a bowl.
Alice: 好给外国人一点震撼
Alice: Okay, let's give the foreigners a shock.
Lucia:  我觉这个锅用来热牛奶也太
Lucia: I think this pot is too... to heat milk.
Lucia:  哈哈也太但是好像没有别的锅了
Lucia: Haha, but it seems like we don't have any other pots.
Alice: 放油了吗
Alice: Did you add oil?
Tasha:放了 我没有用过这个锅煎饼
Tasha: Yes, I did. I've never used this pot to make pancakes.
Alice: 啊这这油有点多
Alice: Ah, this oil is a bit much.
Tasha: 有点多是吧哈哈
Tasha: It's a bit much, right? Haha.
Alice: 就这样我我
Alice: Just like this, I...
Tasha: 那倒出来一些吧
Tasha: Then pour some out.
Alice: 你你没地方倒吧
Alice: But you don't have anywhere to pour it, right?
Alice: 你就那样吧
Alice: Just leave it like that.
Alice: 留在锅里一点也没事
Alice: Leaving a bit in the pot is fine.
Alice: 抽油烟机抽油烟机
Alice: Turn on the range hood, range hood.
Tasha: 啊好好好熏呀
Tasha: Ah, okay, okay, it's smoking a lot.
Alice: 别闻这个味
Alice: Don't inhale the smell.
Alice: 这个味太
Alice: This smell is too...
Alice: 火还可以
Alice: The flame is okay.
Tasha:呜
Tasha: Ugh.
Alice: 小心一点
Alice: Be careful.